okay we are back
up
um this Interruption brought to you by
Xfinity I really got to change the
internet or something the plan with this
it's ridiculous they have it going down
like once a day at this
point looks like we still have a few
people on Twitch maybe the YouTube ones
will find it
again I took a second to go make myself
a shake in the meanwhile so at least I
don't forget to have anything all day
today
um where were we
here right we were just fixing the last
bugs in here let me dry my hands
off we were just fixing the last bugs in
this port and then hopefully we'll be
able to run
it so here we have the entity render
color
tint uh I think this is just white isn't
it oh but we potentially change it yeah
we'll just do like this
color
and draw
bars single pass compiler this has to go
above my bad
forgot about
okay
1692 we have a few things in here it
looks
like okay cyan doesn't exist so
oops that s right like
that
it oh no that's not the problem problem
is we forgot the close bracket here
race perfect now we
are back to where we were before which
is down to
here uh expected six arguments right
there's some
defaults for
false
believe
here uh I actually don't know what
happened here let's see
MOA I
entity
renders after draw bars you need to get
the tile
right Rd of Y and X oh that's the uh
that's the entity position
is in PID is going to be render entities
of I right and then you get the
PID 1 you
continue uh and then we
do int
y x like this maybe
source rect is equal to well this is
wrong
right rectangle source rect and then Des
that passing
int
Origin uh back
two
57 uh and we're almost done this is end
mode 2D like
68 I thought we defined Q color I guess
not
uh do I thought we defined Q cool down
as
well in
and did I mess up my Loops or something
here
so there are those Loops
right uh this one didn't get
closed and
then this one did get
closed and then this one gets closed
here
nit
game
it game renderer yeah we got that and
then close game
H what's this
[Music]
function this is just render so this
should be render
Health uh right because I don't do I
don't actually use these yet
because I don't use these yet because
the string formatting is really annoying
we'll do that in a second let's get this
working
unus variable color we don't
working unus variable color we don't need this for
1901 uh yeah I remember this
[Music]
is Vector
well I don't know how the hell it came
up with this because this is like
literally
rectangle okay so here we have W dra
lines
ex dra rectangle lines ex ex
here three
[Music]
warnings on
color off color let's just do
this
oops I hate this like I don't know why
it does
this okay I hate that it like
automatically tries to extend the
freaking
comments and skill 173 I think this
one's just legitimately
unused
okay so now this actually compiles
quick 400 Lin
ported take a quick little break here to
have some of the shake
check Twitter
651 interestingly this is has higher
watch time um than my
thesis but is not getting into the
this has like a way better curve even
than my
thesis this is interesting at the start
that this happens
saw your defense first well my defense
was
right welcome back as well uh YouTube
decided Well xinity decided to take us
down for a
bit I don't know we'll see about the
video I'm kind of surprised because it
has good watch time on it I'm surprised
um it hasn't gotten done any better than
it's done so
build I'm sure we have to fix runtime
bugs
fix but I think that we might it's only
5:17 so I probably have another two and
a half three hours on this and um all I
have to really do is fix a few bugs in
order to get at least some semblance of
the renderer working in pure C
okay entity health entity Max Health
interesting this thing should be
initialized we can comment draw bars
calls for
now they're not super important
and now are we failing
84 I'm not
calling bars from anywhere
right so I'm assuming that these line
addresses are not actually accurate then
one and why can't it show me the
uh why can't show me where it's crashing
wait file loaded
successfully
image and then it's got to be right here
right the MOBA
assets I don't know why it's not giving
me the
address any basic RL implementation
papers you'll recommend
what do you mean implementation papers
you mean algorithm
papers they really aren't like papers on
How to implement stuff
right I know lots of papers but depends
what you
want bro got an ad on his own channel I
just saw that that's funny yeah they do
that it's ridiculous so I mean honestly
if you saw my uh the video I really
think that that you kind of just need po
most of the time um but implementing PO
is a total pain in the ass so if you're
trying to learn if you haven't ever
implemented any RL algorithms and you're
just trying to learn I just suggest
implementing like vanilla policy
gradients Costa has a good thing on that
with clean RL I think car pathy has a
good thing on that from way way way back
when um that's generally what I would
suggest doing and then after that you
can look at like the clean RL code for
newer algorithms
or puffer or whatever um but generally I
don't think where I don't think that at
the moment algorithms is where the
progress is happening progress is like
if you want to make progress algorithms
is not where you spend your time
why is it SE bolting when loading the
texture
let me go check the RB stuff because I
haven't done this in the Capi
[Music]
before not that I don't want this I want
the examples don't I
texture there's nothing special
happening here there's no like weird in
code or anything
do you have to do a knit window first
you shouldn't
right let's go check how I implemented
this in the python version
oh wait I do init the window first hold
on maybe I'm just
dumb maybe I'm just
dumb let's just put this up higher maybe
right oh yo guys
uh I don't know what this is but uh we
have
something there lots of little puffers
wandering
around
so
something we'll have to fix some bugs
but that's all it was it actually does
run that's
awesome I'm surprised like even the
Shader is somewhat working
right somewhat
working you can see right here these are
the
minions even the controls seem to be
working a little
bit well that's nice now if only only uh
Xfinity hadn't decided to shut the
stream off when we had people actually
watching it ah looks like a few folks
are back on YouTube
Welcome I should add like a sponsored by
xfin like you know outages sponsored by
Xfinity until they fix it
I don't know if I need to init this
camera offset
thing what happens if I don't well okay
if I don't then that gives
you look at
this got you a Cod
version get you a coder version of a
NASCAR jacket
now man that's trying way too
hard that's trying way too
hard you can kind of see the map here yo
Sal uh this is right here this is the
first we just got this working a second
ago um obviously there's a bunch of
stuff to fix there's some bugs but this
is the first version running in purec
there's no python
here so this could theoretically compile
for
web can you do shaders on
web I think you should be able to
glorious well it's clearly like
mismapped somehow so we'll have to
figure that
watch you can see that the cursor is
more or less accurate
now what if I do this
whoa I mean technically even this
scaling works
right and you
can you can see the uh the pattern in
the background as
that something how you set cells
probably
what it's funny
right how silly it
is I also don't know why
uh it looks like the map is somehow
backwards as well or
something we'll see about
that oh let's see if the Escape key
works yeah it
bites direct leak of a lot of
bites it's a lot of bites to leak
size well this would be the problem
right renderer cell
gigantic uh not sure what it's doing
there
cell size width and height
right ah so this width times cell
maybe with
height we have 41 by 23 is what it set
oops okay so now this is the right
window size right this is like what we
had before the right window
size and now it's just the background
that's like way off or whatever
so like if I just go by where the towers
are I'm at Mid now right this is mid
this is the enemy Tower oh no this is my
tower now this up here is mid and now I
can
technically I can see I'm using
abilities
right when I press keys so pretty much
everything looks like it's actually
working then their Tower kills me so
everything is working except that the
map is wrong somehow or the camera is
wrong more likely the
we've got cool art being made got to
have it online
layouts I mean we want to do something
pretty darn simple but yeah if you want
to do like a little UI bar of
something basically the elements that
we're going to have in the UI is we need
to have like your Q your W and like the
cool down or whatever qwe and cool down
we don't we really don't need to make
icons for all the different skills right
that's like way too much work like why
should we need 15 icons just for like
yeah I'm trying to think what else would
be cool to
do I think you'll be able I'm hoping
that you'll get some inspiration when I
like I'm going to put this on the web
basically as soon as I can as soon as
it's like Rel relatively working and
then you'll just be able to play it
right and then you can decide like what
you think would be cool I think you're
going to be able to figure stuff out way
way better as soon as I just give you a
playable
build you can have fun with puffer
defense of the puffer or League of
puffers
I'm trying to see where uh the camera
offset
so this is where the camera Target gets
at right here right
correct I believe our tile size is 32
right yeah it's 32
can I figure out like what would be
weird with
this like I'm way over here right and
then if I expand
this we're at the bottom corner of the
map
I have to be giving this to the Shader
wrong
right I would think I'm giving this to
the Shader
wrong the Shader cat is also
garbage we'll ignore that for
right well we'll figure out how to do
that regardless because we'll have to
have shaders
Target
dox these things are
fine it's probably going to be something
like the
[Music]
way Shader camera X
my brain has too much to split out
design
factors to spit out on design factors so
I'll have to catch you on a call
sometime with sketches in hand that's
totally
good I'm
around we haven't seen anything from uh
from Nathan yet on the the other
environment either but Nathan says he's
finishing his thesis soon like in the
next week and then's going to be doing
all sorts of cool stuff there
too A lot of it is dependent on the
features to be added I don't know how
much we're going to do on the features I
don't know if we're going to go to super
crazy on
stuff not at least not initially I want
to get this thing like end to end
playable and have some cool RL on it
okay so this is what I was thinking
before is that this was going to be like
are yeah so this set Shader value is is
weird
right this is probably what it
is int local
index void star
so this is just not going to
get saved
Shader I just need Shader X and Shader y
it's really that easy
I think I'm right here so I think what's
happening is there's a discrepancy
between how you do this in Python and in
C and in C because you're passing a raw
pointer what you have to do is you have
to do um like float Shader X and Float
Shader
Y and then this thing here this is like
slop code where is
it is this slop okay yeah float main r
Shader this should
be uh
[Music]
renderer Shader y right and then this is
going to be render Shader
X and then this should just
be camera X pointer should just be
and render Shader X like
this and this one render a Shader
y and and now I don't need these things
because these are garbage uh this time
as well I need Shader
seconds uh right CU Shader time here
this is yeah this is the
location
and we do renderer Shader time seconds
is going to be time of
null and then this
one Sher
seconds
build okay that's like that looks a lot
better now our map is no longer
screwy I think we're still off by a
little
low frame rate's really low for some
reason
work there's literally no format text I
don't know what it thinks it's
doing what screen resolution like 720 is
it's variable
though it's variable
res that's very easy to code in
let's see I'm sure that they have some
text demo with rayb
percent
I text form like this
Del
time z f
oh this is doing manual frame rate
stuff custom frame control we don't want
this
there's got to be like a demo that just
shows how to print out FPS
draw there's literally a draw
FPS I'm
okay so it is running 60fps just not
it's not doing the uh the smoothing
correctly look you can see that when I
move my mouse around there's a little
ball that follows it around smoothly
it's just not uh it's not doing the
rendering smoothly so we'll figure that
out and it'll immediately look way
better I'll pick a standard one for
pixel art
scaling I think I'm using 128 right now
but if you're drawing at a lower res
yeah just exact upscale and you'll be
it it's jittering a little bit so we'll
have to fix some
stuff why is it jittering
it Jitters when it
moves oh I bet there's like an INT or
something there's probably like an INT
cast that's
right and I think like the map is off by
a pixel or two yeah you can see like
these lines are in the wrong spot as
well but we're definitely getting
sh
960 hold on that's
crazy now that's crazy man 960 by 540 is
like nobody has 1080p
monitors I did uh this is 720 by 1080 I
did half size of a 1440p
we still nervous seahorse yeah you can
still see the jedar right
renders
TX TS
how did we get around this in the
original hey may I ask what you're doing
I am
porting this Mook
game which is written in scyon for the
most part mix of scyon and python to run
in pure C this runs at like a million
steps per second so the goal is to have
an ultra Ultra fast miniature MOBA for
reinforcement
learning so that we can and train RL to
play this game and use this as a really
nice environment for testing new methods
and
such the port has only been on for I
think I've been doing this two and a
half days now or whatever it's about
2,000 lines of
C I do
python yeah the original is uh I think I
wrote the original renderer for this in
Python and then the simulators are in
scon so the one thing with this type of
work you can't write the simulators in
Python it's too slow but you can write
it in something that's basically python
have you ever used
syon let me link you
something cuz this is a really nice
thing for devs to pick
up it's very close you'll
see I'll show you here this is a more
minimal example I'll link this to
you uh unfortunately wait restream's
chat is dying I can't link this hold
on come on
chat try this so this is 200 lines to
implement
snake and uh this will run nice and fast
it's very easy to learn how to do this
if you know
Python
and if you check on our website
here the C Port of it can be played in
your
browser it's pretty similar versus a
whole bunch of reinforcement learned
doing it's been going fairly well there
just a couple little bugs here and there
to
catch I'm trying to think what this
would
be this got to be like a Bad cast
somewhere like why else would it be
jittering can I figure out where I
remember fixing this on the python code
is the annoying thing and I don't
remember how I did
sure we've got a whole bunch of people
doing uh
cool environment Dev around
this is correct
right entity last
X tick Frack
times xus last X yeah this is a
float and
yes what happens if I just said
um TS to
be a float does it do
anything you can kind of see it here
like the way this thing moves is just
jittery right
much these lines are also completely
wrong then fix those first
y maybe this is a
[Music]
clue the fact that this uh renders like
completely wrong
two it's interesting to me that the API
is different for
this don't see
is something is definitely screwy
here
top like where's it go where is it
coming from is it just coming from all
the way at the top of the screen or is
there actually a spot that it's coming
from
is the X and Y flip like
what how does it move over time like
that that's bizarre isn't
weird let's just go get like an attack
over to here
though
okay so
like line start line
time I put the link what's the project
I'll Google it YouTube sensors links
Google why you putting code on Google
Drive man
GitHub oops just minimized all my stuff
by
dude I strongly
suggest doing uh stuff on
GitHub like nobody sees projects on
Google
Drive I would highly suggest fixing that
and GitHub is like the single most
important source of code
I'd very strongly recommend fixing
that something is definitely wrong here
because
the target position
here is moving around a
ton oh you see it last X last y That's
it right
there
computer see you
this work
now
that okay it still doesn't
work the
heck asked
why but did I not
one let's do one like this here it's
rebuilding now yeah now we're the
Assassin character
our abilities don't really do anything
do they just get
the line end is wrong
right target picks Target
y Target PX Target
py Target X Target
y x
oh it totally messes this up
now yeah Okay cool so now now the
abilities actually show up correctly for
the most
part so this is closer to what we needed
right H we're still
dead okay but that's a little a little
better do we want what do we want to fix
next the
Jitter I'm trying to think about the
Jitter I think it was just like a pixel
alignment thing but I'm trying to
recommend I'm trying to remember
how I fix
that maybe I have some clue
here okay this is where it gets
y yeah these lines are actually
correct and we have Ty and TX
get cast to
in I round this instead is that going to
be
yeah that's
fine TX t y tile size TI
size I didn't round these in uh in
Python I didn't have to do that right
and it was
smooth why was this smooth in
Python that is the question
[Music]
right TX
Ty and then you draw a source Rec Des
Rec which is TX
Ty SI TI
size in entity y
size tick Frack times I mean is this
last X last
y the same
code the same exact
code I think it is at
least I'm trying to think what would be
different in C and python
here what the heck would possibly be
different
let's go fix that ability real quick
because
um it's kind of weird that that wasn't
working can I use it like What's
Happening Here
buff AO it should be AOE and then TP
right wait it's
AOE
teleport but I don't think this is
actually working is
it no that's a t that is an AOE I think
it's doing like the wrong thing this
just feels like it's using the burst
okay so it's definitely just using the
wrong
skills it's using the uh the burst
character skills
interesting we'll have to figure that
out but that's at least now we
know at least now we know that it's not
the skill that's failing
so if we're going to be using this
anyways it's first nuke first AOE burst
done I
believe right
oh it's uh I think it's the carry
somehow
it's got to be the
carry be
dead
okay so if the slow icon comes up then
it's the carry
right yeah you can see right here
there's the slow icon
interesting I don't know why that would
happen regardless
though really like to fix this render
bug
just not
smooth I'm trying to I'm just trying to
remember what it was cuz like I remember
fixing this I remember fixing this exact
thing and I thought that it was that you
had to do the Math First In floating
point and then convert afterwards to int
but that doesn't seem to work here
there was like this Jitter effect right
it was the exact same thing before and I
remember that I fixed it and I'm trying
to remember how I fixed
stream it wasn't that long ago right
wasn't it last
week was it two weeks ago that we were
fixing the Jitter
4721 got the
Jitters well I don't do you remember
what I was talking about like we had the
same exact thing the other
day oops
grab it so this is the mobo
right isn't it like jittering a little
bit you can see it's jittering a little
bit
right maybe this is how it was moving
though I just paint the
pictures it seems like it's jittering a
little bit it's not like super bad we'll
have to fix it
though because it's really Jank
well in the meantime let's maybe we
figure out the actions
thing enes human
player and then
actions where do we set
oh well this is garbage code I don't
know
where I honestly don't even know where
it got this
yeah this totally just filled with AI
slop that's on me for not checking the
super Maven
completions use q and player Q
timer yeah it's really just like the
auto complete
okay do we
have yeah now look now I actually have
my
skills and I can actually play the class
right this class feels great
because uh this movement bug really
needs to be fixed though I can it's very
obvious look at this though
zoom and then
assassinate and then Retreat to base and
Tower kills
everything to mob do like
uh pretty
nice I like playing puffer mooba puffer
mooba is fun game
I really do have to figure out the
smooth movement though it makes the
whole thing feel just
Jank do I actually just start looking
through my old
bods I remember this being like a really
bad bug to try to fix
this was the
shaders I'd already fixed Movement by
then
I'm pretty
sure yeah this is me trying to debug
right
here this was me trying to fix this bug
for like an hour I found the exact
clip look at these compile times they're
God awful
I don't remember what I had for
breakfast I do because I always have the
same thing there you
look yeah you can see how much smoother
it looks on this
though e
I'm trying to see where I actually show
the where I solved it
D I literally can't find this it's right
here
where did I freaking figure out this
damn bug though
yeah this is literally me staring at the
same piece of code two weeks ago
oh was it the camera
movement
so literally if i' like turn my chair
here this is me in the background
solving this exact same
yep I was right me and the video thank
you for me and the
video oh I find it I got it [ __ ] me damn
it demonetized whatever
um
gosh yeah damn [ __ ]
casts you have to align the camera to be
Pixel Perfect is what it was
okay let me show you this thing I'm
going to finish the shake I'm going to
show you what this looks like use a
restroom reset a little bit and then I'm
going to get another hour and a half
working
so it actually feels good now we have to
you can see that the tiles are like one
or two off we'll have to fix that but
there's no more like Jank movement it
feels very smooth
this you know I can burst them down I
can like you know I can kite a little
bit or whatever and I can get wrecked
because I'm bad but we have to do the UI
but do you see that this just it feels
so much smoother now I don't know if you
can tell on camera but it's a totally
different game
right you can like Lane against this guy
like
this all
right the
I can't tell if the Shader is actually
working I don't see the glow effect
working you can see the background at
least the texture is
tower that's pretty
cool all right rest real quick and then
we're going
to do some more stuff on this but we're
very close to having this like web ready
very
close I don't know if it's going to
happen today but it'll be very
welcome we fixed the
bug so this is now what we're working
with in pure
CA go like this we can
dive and if we recover a little bit of
Mana we can burst cool
and then we can maybe
Escape oh the towers don't shoot
neutrals we still get away very
cool needs the animations on it but like
movement's pretty Snappy
map is a couple tiles off I believe one
tile
okay do we do the
um the text draw
stuff let's do the let's fix the UI real
quick and I can't believe I found this
in like an older stream I found like the
thing that I had messed up
before it was the fact that I heard
myself say oh is it the camera like the
camera that's wrong yeah it was the
camera that was messed
function there's a there's a text format
function which appears to take variable
numbers of arcs
so I'm assuming it has like some macro
stuff CU that's kind of hard to do isn't
it and
see my memory is usually pretty good for
random
things if you ask me somebody's name
that I've only met like 30 times I won't
know it but if you ask me like some
absolute abely random fact from like 10
years ago I'll know it
perfectly I don't know my memory is
weird as
hell like I can tell you a jiffy is a
100th of a second because I read uh I
read it in some random fact app in
middle school and then it happened be a
quiz question and everyone's like how
the hell do you know
that why do I remember that I have no
idea
steps SL jiffies that actually would be
really
funny we do 10,000 steps per
jippy I might do that that's kind of a
fun that'd be a fun gag
all right so let's do the spring
formatting 10,000 steps per
jippy thank you very much
all so this is draw
text so we'll do
draw
text text
format I'm to think of it it's actually
kind of weird the random stuff I
I have like a really bad visual memory
as
well like I don't remember the way
things look
necessarily I it's like way more
symbolic I remember audio very well
oddly like I'll remember the exact
intonation on a million different
know okay here's our
UI look at
that UI nice yeah you can see us
pressing buttons
you what the heck was this supposed to
be
colored EC color I think that's wrong I
think that this needs to just be this
should just be like off
yeah there you go so you can see the
timer highlighted correctly now
right let's do the other draw text
function
okay you can see now we have our XP
values here right so our UI
think this is kind of crazy that I have
this working in C I'm not going to
lie like the fact that this entire thing
is in C freaking 2,000 lines of
C 2K lines of
see it's pretty
I want to overload you with feature
requests I think you should probably
play it first to be fair um we're going
to have to do the animation system make
it 10 no not 10K lines man that's huge
at 10K is
like like brother if you're doing 10K
lines of C you better have like a a
company making seven figures of Revenue
like you know
lines if I read 100,000 lines of c and
I'm not like you know solor running a a
giant company with like you know [ __ ]
tons of Revenue I'm GNA be mad
right
H I'm pretty sure WhatsApp was like 40
th000 lines or
something really doesn't take that much
code to totally just change
everything you it's kind of cool you can
just like you can like write a few days
worth of code and just like do something
completely out of left field that
nobody's ever
done I has anybody ever written A moit
and C that runs a million
FPS I'm sure we're going to have to perf
optimize the C version now right but
that's pretty
I mean maybe we just play it a little
bit and see what's looks
buggy so I mean this just expands nicely
right and now we're still 60 FPS this
would lag in the python
version um but
here it's is it
faster you shouldn't be moving faster
same we should fix the map bug that's a
big one right let's fix the map bug and
maybe the Shader
bug zap getting Zapped by Towers this
looks so cool
though this pretty
all right let's figure out the uh the
map Shader and
PC and the M.C file like the demo file
is only 29 Lin so it's basically it's
pretty much on the dot uh 2K lines of
see
we're going have some more work to do
I'm sure
but I'm going to enjoy this for a
minute we already fixed this
one like this actually feels easy to
maintain to be honest as well like the
way that this is written this feels very
easy to edit and maintain
and actually like at least is maybe even
easier than the python I'm not going to
lie
[Music]
um I'm trying to think how we fix the
map bug
is this not the
same colon colon
2 game map should be identical
here is it off by one in the renderer
somehow or the Shader
divide by
right also the Shader isn't doing um the
border color correctly is
it does the Border color look like it's
moving like it's uh it's
right there's no like breath effect on
it
oh this gives
you a time
this is
obnoxious I remember solving this as
well it's literally just the time
counter being in the wrong
resolution actually didn't I do this in
the scon version
already or no I didn't right I did
no I wouldn't have because it's in the
yeah yeah hold on
see this is standard IO and time. H
perfect
is anything
happening don't think so
I'm taking way too long on this really
basic
thing I just don't want to like I know
how to do this I just don't want to do
the really gross way you
want process
time yeah we want Zer to
one
wait process
time shouldn't this be correct
[Music]
that's
silly well it's way too fast now right
and I don't need this to be a function
either I only use it once
this I really don't want to do the easy
way to fix it though
excuse
me
yeah well this is not glowing correctly
now so that's
we
go messy but
I just saw
that now you can see the nice effect we
got this nice
glow right oops hello puffers you all
are a little bit
right we need to clamp somehow because
the texture is
repeats I really like the assassinate
jump
nice and it's also it's kind of cool how
like we have um we actually if you
notice we have the map in a higher
resolution now so we need to figure we
have to fix this cuz it's like
something's a little off I think it's
like a tile off
maybe yeah this looks like it's a full
tile off at least right maybe two tiles
off well it's weird because like it's
not off here like this is
perfect right but
then
oh that's weird why can you not go in
this way but you can go
in yeah this is like off
somehow but
still I also I like how you can like
hold down the button so like I'm just
holding my Dash here and then I can just
Dash in at max range pretty
nice why do you take damage
when I don't know there's probably some
weird stuff going
though on W Gilla I don't know then that
would be
weird that'd be very
weird well we have the Shader fixed
now what about the map can I figure out
why the map is like slightly
there's got to be a better way of doing
this I'm sure
it's kind of weird that they all like
get sent it seems like it messes up
their pathing when you do that
but that
right I figure this will let you play
around with them once I uh we put it on
the web
I don't know if there's an easy way to
do this
this is good this is what I was looking
for